hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into
practice I've studied and taught
Philosophy for over 20 years and I find
that many people run into difficulties
reading classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured but the
concepts themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them
useful what you're currently watching is
part of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on One Core concept
from an important philosophical text I
hope you find it useful as
well one of the consistent themes that
we see running throughout Raina Maria
R's letters to a young poet which really
could be be letters to a potential poet
or possible poet this young man who's
writing poetry and will also end up
pursuing a military profession one of
the main themes is that of trust and
that's how it's often translated in
English the term that actually gets used
over and over again it's not wrong to
translate it as trust but it's a verb
Halon which literally means to cling to
to stick with to uh cleave to we could
say if we're going to use an older
English word and so there's a kind of
active element to it it's not trust in
the sense of oh I don't have to do
anything there's this thing over there
that's going to take care of me and I
can be purely passive there's an an
active
and enduring you could say aspect to it
and I'm not going to say that the very
first place we encounter it is letter
eight but that's one that we should look
at because we see it coming up in letter
after letter and here the framing is not
so much trust in things ding but trust
in what is
difficult right so he's going to tell us
that um we arrange our life or if and if
only we arrange our life in accordance
to the principal grun zat there he's
actually using this as a technical term
principle something that we would follow
and I I really like the German term zat
means proposition or sentence or
something like that and grund basic at
the foundation of things so a principle
is something that we govern ourselves in
relation to and what is this principle
he says that we must always trust in or
cling to the difficult now why would we
do that well because we are encountering
a life
and as he talks about situations and
society in which we're continually being
offered the easy he actually talks about
the easiest of the easy and we don't
want to be seduced by that if things are
easy not a problem we don't have to
reject it and say oh I must pursue the
difficult for its own sake but when
things do become difficult that's when
we have the greatest possibility of
encountering something more more real
something more valuable something that
will allow us to transform and
interestingly in this letter in that
section he actually Begins by talking
about people being cowardly and
rejecting um the so-called spirit world
death all of these things ding that are
so closely related to us and he says
through our daily defensiveness these
have been p ped out of life that the
senses with which we might have been
able to grasp them have atrophied and
then he says to say nothing of God uh
but fear of the inexplicable has not
only impoverished the reality of the
individual it has narrowed the
relationship between one human being and
another which has as it were been lifted
out of the riverbed of infinite
possibilities and sat down in a place on
the bank where nothing happens and he
goes on and talks about the things that
scare us maybe really in themselves
they're not that scary he says maybe all
these ancient myths that stand at the
beginning of all Races the myths about
dragons that are at the last moment
transformed into princesses perhaps all
the dragons in our lives are princesses
who are only waiting to see us act just
once with beauty and
courage perhaps everything that
frightens us is in its deepest Essence
something helpless that wants our love
so by trusting by clinging to by
sticking with by enduring we can allow
things to reveal their true selves to
us this is not the only thing that he
has to say about this matter by any
means and if we go back to an earlier l
letter number seven we're going to see
him talking about trust as well so in
letter seven he's he's talking about uh
capus and his Solitude and he tells him
it's clear we must trust in what is
difficult again we see this this
principle right we must trust in what is
difficult and here we get a kind of
explanation or analogy that's being put
forward everything alive trusts in it
that what is difficult everything in
nature grows and defends itself any way
it can and is spontaneously itself tries
to be itself at all costs and against
all
opposition and then he goes on and he
says we know little but we must trust in
what is that we must trust in what is
difficult is a certainty height
something we can rely upon that will
never abandon us
once leave us
behind you know leave us you you could
say in the Lurch to use one of our
English Expressions so if we stick with
what is difficult we're not going to
lose out which is our great fear that
motivates us and so he goes on and he
says it is good to be solit
for Solitude is difficult and we'll come
back to that in a moment Solitude is one
of those great things as he calls them
now in letter four we get uh an another
interesting discussion of trust and here
it is trust in things so he's talking
about um writing from Paris actually
having left Paris and being on this
Great Northern plane and he
says
um there's a a problem that you have to
deal with a problem that you have to
figure out uh a question and feeling
that have a life of their own and even
the most articulate people won't be able
to help right and he says I think you
will not have to remain without a
solution an aling a resolution to these
matters if you trust again we have that
word Halton in
things what kind of things like the ones
that my eyes are now resting upon the
German term there is an those that are
similar to it he is seeing the landscape
and the matters of Nature and he's
saying you don't have to see the same
Panorama that I do but things that are
of the same kind so nature itself being
in nature if you trust in nature in what
is simple in nature in the small things
that hardly anyone sees and that can can
so suddenly become huge immeasurable so
not just that we look at a pine cone or
you know a fly or the way in which the
snow is falling off of a spruce tree or
something like that and suddenly it
becomes big because it occupies our
vision it becomes unmeasurable
uncomparable to other things it occupies
us we have attentiveness towards it and
he says if you have this love for what
is humble and try very simply as someone
who serves to win the confidence of what
see seems poor then everything will
become easier for you more coherent and
somehow more
reconciling not in your conscious mind
perhaps which stays
behind astonished but in your innermost
awareness awakeness and knowledge and
here he's got one of his wonderful lines
going on that doesn't have to do so much
with this theme of trust but does in
some way connect with it he says I would
beg you as well as I can to have
patience with everything unresolved in
your heart and to try to love the
questions themselves as if they were
locked rooms or books L written in a
very foreign language don't search for
the answers which could not be given to
you now because you would not be able to
live them the point is to live
everything live the questions now
perhaps then someday far in the future
you will gradually without even noticing
it live your way into the answer so you
could say that there's a different kind
of trust being called upon there we are
to trust these things of nature which we
think of as outside of ourselves but
we're also to trust what is within us
the very processes and the fact that our
conscious Minds aren't containing all of
the answers to this a little bit later
on in letter four he's going to talk
about
um bodily Delight light and how we've
we've transformed it into something more
superficial and he says
that all Beauty in animals and plants is
a silent enduring form of love and
yearning the solitary man can see the
animals as he sees plants patiently and
willingly uniting and multiplying and
growing not out of physical pleasure not
out of physical pain but bowing to
Necessities that are greater than
Pleasure and Pain and more power
powerful than will and withstanding if
only human beings could more humbly
receive this
mystery which the world is filled with
even in his smallest
things could bear it endure it more
solemnly feel how terribly heavy it is
instead of taking it lightly and now so
that's other things he goes on as well
and says if only they could be more
reverent toward their own fre
fruitfulness to guard their own
fruitfulness then they would be uh you
know freed towards this possible
creativity this Rapture right um that
goes beyond mere Bly Delight what a
wonderful way of thinking about things
in letter six we're going to see a very
important discussion he's writing uh his
inter interlocutor again and he his
interlocutor has presumably been worried
about the superficiality the
conventionality of the situation that
he's been placed in and reala tells him
there isn't any that is in itself vast
and spacious and connected to the
important things the gross and the great
things right the that the truest kind of
life or if we want to stick closer to
the German the actual life real life as
we call it often contrasting it against
conventional life V right laan is
connected with and he goes on and tells
us that only the individual who is
solitary can actually have this only the
individual whose solitary is placed
under the deepest
laws like a thing now this is not a
resorting to mechanism or something like
that because things themselves are
animate have a kind of intentionality as
a matter of fact in another place RKA
will talk about the things coming out to
meet us and what are these things well
he tells us um if there's nothing that
you can share with other people try to
be close to things they will not abandon
you again we see this theme of you can
trust in things and the kns are still
there and the winds that move through
the trees and across many lands
everything in the world of things and
animals is still filled with happening
which you can take part in and children
are still the way you were as a child
sad and happy in just the same way and
if you think about your childhood you
once again live among them this Echoes
the advice that he gave in the very
first letter telling his interloc to go
into the depths of your childhood that
you still contain within your self trust
in it
right now what are the great serious
important difficult things solitude is
one of them this is a key theme as well
not only in these letters but so many of
other letters addressed to other people
by RKA but he's also going to talk and
uh this is going to be uh in letter six
and in other letters as well about um
love right and uh he's going to talk
about this even more in um seven so so
he says it's good to love because love
is difficult for one human being to love
another human being that is perhaps the
most difficult task that has been
entrusted to us the ultimate task the
final test in proof the work for which
all other work is merely preparation and
he says young people they're not ready
for that you have to age and mature and
not everybody who ages and matures is
going to do this and this is the letter
in which we find that love is two
solitudes protecting each other but what
else
death the death of those we care about
the death we encounter the death that
will inevitably take all of us to be
dead is not fully to be dead for RKA and
we could talk about that in other poems
and letters but it is something that we
have to face it is one of these
difficult heavy things that we can
encounter and come to embrace within our
Solitude God RKA has some very
interesting ideas about what God is and
tells his interlocutor you probably have
never had the god you think you lost God
is something that we are building like
flies G Gathering
honey so that's another thing you see
that there's the the simple small things
of nature or of our own memories but
there's also these massive we could say
metaphysical matters and I would say
that the relationship between hum one
human being and another whether it's
love or other modalities also figures
into this panoply of things that we are
being being called to have trust in
Friendship
companionship perhaps even rivalry or
misunderstanding provided we adopt this
attitude of trust of sticking with
things we can experience a much greater
and richer life whether we can actually
communicate that with other people the
degree to which they can share in it
model themselves after our own that's an
entirely contingent matter as RKA
realizes but it is
certainly something that we can talk
about as he has in these letters that we
can reflect upon and think about and
once we have a inkling of it something
that we can desire for ourselves and
then put into practice within our own
lives